current government regulations require
about 98 billion dollars to be on the
books of our banks
we have a little more than that
we have 2.4 trillion dollars in excess
of our reserves
i think that's a lot of money
you could do a lot of work with that
money if that money got invested into
businesses
what does that mean in terms of scale
it's about two-thirds of the entire
federal budget
that is a lot of money just sitting
there
just like it did in the great depression
but where do banks have their money
maybe their money's already tied up in
risky business ventures they don't want
any more is that the case
no that's also not the case
this is a graph
of business loans and consumer loans i
checked this 16 different ways i
couldn't believe it when i saw this
that right now consumer debt is around
three and a half
um three and a half trillion
and
this is this is business loans this is
like negligible it's like a few hundred
billion dollars
97 percent less
i don't know about you
but this is not how capitalism is
supposed to work
those are supposed to be flip-flopped
that's how economies grow they don't
grow through consumer debt
but if you're curious about how this
happened there's a book
that i wrote
called borrow
that i can tell you about how that
happened but basically the idea is that
it became much easier
to securitize all this consumer debt to
bundle it up and sell it on capital
markets
than it is for business debt in fact
it's not possible really to do that now
and in fact um
our largest government agency that's
supposed to be in charge of doing this
doing what we imagined what what the
reconstruction finance corporation did
in the 1930s uh the the small business
administration
does hardly any of it so 15 billion
dollars this is this is like a drop in
the bucket compared to either the size
of banks or even the entire market for
small business loans if you include real
estate
why is this
it's because we had government policies
in the 1960s and 70s that made it
possible to securitize consumer debt to
make it easier for banks and lenders and
investors to put money into your credit
cards that into your small business then
into even your large business
and this is from a report from the uh
federal reserve
report to congress why it's not possible
to do this
now i think if it's possible to hide
greek debt by goldman sachs
if it's possible for all those wizards
of wall street to do all the magic they
do every day we can probably do for
small business debt what we did for
houses
in texas in the 1930s before they had
computers or you know anything really
they're just primitive cavemen that's in
texas
that's point one
point two
it would not fix the new leading sector
how do we find this new leading sector
for instance we're all excited about
self-driving cars who's excited about
self-driving cars i'm excited about
self-driving cars
i hate driving
i like sleeping and reading
now this will create a lot of demand i'm
very excited this is a good thing it'll
create a lot of demand though not just
for the cars the replacement of our cars
but also the rebuilding of our cities
the rebuilding of our entire built
environment around these cars a lot of
connections a lot of growth this is the
kind of thing that could be part of a
new leading sector it is the right
direction now the other thing i want to
talk about with that
is
that sounded crazy how many years ago
two
three years ago if i was here five years
ago i was like hey i'm making a
self-driving car you're like yeah good
luck with your rocket boots
and yet it's possible
it's a failure of imagination in fact we
see this all the time in our society a
failure of imagination which stems from
a basic failure of science which can we
come back to
we live in an era that is not disruptive
but incrementalist
bear with me
most of the science we build our
technology on the basic scientific
principles electricity quantum mechanics
have resulted in products that have been
refined since the 1960s
since the 1950s even a lot of ways
incrementalist
it's no been just been no this room
basically would look the same 50 years
ago whereas 50 years before that none of
it would exist
we think we live in a time of
technological change but it's actually
relatively slow
because we have cut off
imagination and we've cut off innovative
science now a good test of what a new
leading sector would be does it sound as
crazy as
a self-driving car
what are some of the kinds of crazy
things you can imagine in the future i
named rocket boots
those sound totally insane i want to
point out one thing that also sounded
ten years ago when i was talking about
this with my wife and we were in grad
school i was like self-driving cars and
space elevators
space elevators right those sound crazy
right yeah a big strip of material into
space with an elevator attached
that's ludicrous
but imagine what it would be like
it's the right order of thinking
something totally totally new
a platform for other industries radical
new materials science and most
importantly
millions and millions of jobs
as a platform for new possibilities
and again i am not an industrialist i am
not a scientist even so i have no stake
in this if this happens i will not make
any money
i will not even be allowed in space
because my wife thinks i'm going to die
there okay
[Music]
you